watch over your children Merkel still in
power
that's the rallying cry here in candles
old town these marches have become part
of everyday life ever since Mia a local
school girl was murdered allegedly by an
Afghan refugee over the weekend about a
hundred people from the woman's Alliance
a far-right group showed up thousands
have turned out every month drawn from
the right wing and neo-nazi groups
across Germany most residents are
outraged candle artist Armin and his
daughter Nina
say it's unbearable people are abusing
our town for their own purposes the
far-right is pretending to have certain
reasons that aren't the real reason
they're here and they're paralyzing us
to endure barricading ourselves at our
house all day with the children because
it's too dangerous to go out not housing
so cane both are mean and Mena are
involved in efforts to combat right-wing
propaganda in town but are mean is now
afraid to put up anti-nazi signs outside
his house the last big demonstration I
couldn't even pin them up on the wall
much less put them up here the neo-nazis
grabbed them out of my hand and
seriously threatened us in march
right-wing extremists and hooligans
broke through the cordon in front of
Armin's gallery and stormed into the
courtyard entryway luckily the police
were there to prevent anything more
serious from happening ever since the
murder of 15 year old me economist Enoch
Street hijacked by heated demonstrations
kundan has become a microcosm of
Germany's internal division striking a
nerve around the country and fueling the
polarized attitudes against migration
discrete lie that super fortunately we
have to expect that there will be more
murders
it's a regrettable situation because of
all the migrants that we've let into
this country less than half - I demand a
fair-minded policy and that the borders
be closed off most people here see
things differently at this demonstration
residents confront the organizer of the
right-wing women's alliance for the
first time face to face you're just
doing this because you hate foreigners
and you want to stop immigration that's
why you're exploiting this murder a
peaceful town festival had been planned
for this weekend and refugees have been
explicitly invited there's a family of
refugees we're looking after who wanted
to come today a mother a father and two
school-aged children but they were
afraid to show up because of the
demonstration in the end not many
residents came the tensions here seem to
have kept many away but our mean Nina
and their fellow citizens want to keep
up the struggle and take back their
beloved scandal